[Musique]
biggie dit
ne rencontre jamais bien tes
héros je l'ai fait
et pourquoi
les Avengers étaient tout ce que j'imaginais
bonjour San Francisco Thor Tony regarde
c'est une
fois
ouais évidemment pensé que je te laisserais
rattraper whoa c'est juste un tout  beaucoup plus
intéressant voyons rapidement
si vous pouvez vous frayer un chemin sur le
pont
[Musique
] merci pour l'aide que
nous avons des civils piégés derrière ces
barricades compris restez derrière moi
je vais m'occuper d'eux
ça devrait être amusant
[  Musique]
s'il te plait es-tu blessé non juste arrête chanceux
pour toi je suis puissant Merci Thor content
de voir que l'aide est en route
]
ça vient
voir vite
pas encombrer
hey reviens ici
viens d'avoir la confirmation que mon convoi de bouclier a
été détourné ce matin mr.  l'un des
trois matins de Fury que je n'ai jamais lu sur
Tony,
ceux-ci sont importants d'accord, quels que soient les
marchés,
la fureur gardait tout mon poing au même
endroit, les roquettes vont déstabiliser
le réfrigérateur ouais je sais que
j'ai construit les [ __ ] de
casquettes, nous devrions sécuriser le
cristal Terrigen si cela  la chose est déjà morte
ce
jour-là en couverture d'accord, lequel d'entre vous
sera un film supplémentaire tiré sur moi avec ma propre
arme, nous vous tiendrons au courant hey ne
savait pas que vous écoutiez il
s'enfuit le vélo ne peut pas ébranler le sentiment que nous
Je suis en train de rattraper quelque chose d'autre qui se passe
ici
là-bas Tony oh rien
tout est juste pêche en espérant que
ces gars n'ont pas
ils le reprennent ils ont un
test de
pulsar  protocoles le
pilote automatique des chimères a pris le dessus sent comme un
braquage nous rentrons en négatif
sécurisons le pont ces armes ne peuvent pas
entrer dans la ville copie que
tu es debout Bruce ouais
moi
sur mon chemin
non je pensais à aujourd'hui pour avoir vos
fan clubs et vos gâteaux en entonnoir
Tony
[Musique]
nous ne les sortons pas
dépêchez-vous le grand gars ne peut pas supporter beaucoup plus de
punition
grand vert j'ai des yeux dessus
Oh apporter le  Quinta tellement riant
[Musique] les
inventions sont dangereuses Stark hé ces
armes étaient destinées aux bons gars
ce n'est pas censé être une blague pas le
temps de mettre la tête dans le jeu cap
ce qui se passe là-bas
pas sûr que l'écrou semble que le réacteur
fonctionne mal  Je reçois des
lectures étranges sur les moniteurs comme si nous
étions attirés par un signal de chaleur dans la
banque
maintenant qui va détruire cette répétition
cette merde J'ai du mal à entendre
Matt est-ce que tu lis
toutes les têtes la chimère est attaquée
évacue le  civils
[Musique]
lisez-vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah
capitaine nous avons un problème le réacteur
ne se stabilise pas La structure moléculaire de Terrigen
se décompose en gaz
c'est extraordinaire si vous ne pouvez pas réparer le
rocher et arriver à  sécurité
Shepard si vous  peut m'entendre le convoi
transporte une bombe perturbatrice sonique hautement mortelle
sur les ennemis destinés à
exploser dans la ville sécuriser l'
actif à la fois
pas de bombe sonique vous plaisantez en
pensant que l'ONU a interdit il y a ces années,
jetons un coup d'œil allons-nous
maintenant c'est une entrée
[Musique]
maître des tâches
nous devons faire exploser ce détonateur pour que la bombe
explose Je pourrais tout liquéfier
dans un rayon de dix milles
Tony ronfle les câbles romanov d'un
ancien agent du SHIELD à un autre
la base du pont est sécurisée les
gars je suis  obtenir ces trois lectures sismiques
je vais prendre ça
tu sais que j'espérais te réparer
n'a pas d'importance j'ai ce [ __ ] de le
remettre viens le chercher en
prenant tes notes habituelles correctement ça
s'appelle des réflexes photographiques
je me suis toujours demandé ce que ça ferait
envie de tuer un Avenger continuez à vous
demander non vous avez volé vos armes au
bouclier
votre danse se termine maintenant
doit être frustrant toujours un pas en
arrière vous allez en faire le vendre
au plus offrant je suis  après
quelque chose d'argent pour un taxi
où est votre enquête vous a laissé
vous n'êtes pas le cerveau derrière cela et
cela sent la distraction j'ai fini de
parler
lâche quel est le problème n'aime pas les
surprises Oh
Dalek la mort ne peut pas apprendre ce que vous pouvez  Je ne
vois pas
[Musique] la
prochaine fois
je suppose que tu as vu ça venir hein
tu penses que tu as gagné de quoi diable
parles-tu regarde assez autour de Rome
le monde se souviendra de ce jour
le jour où leurs héros les ont laissé tomber
ce qui se passe ici
[Musique]
il s'effondre
merde ils nous ont joué Steve peux-tu
m'entendre sortir de là
[Musique]
merde
certains disent qu'ils ont été mis en place d'autres les
appellent des meurtriers est-ce que les Avengers représentent un
danger pour la société c'était la question
Bruce c'était la question eh bien nous tous
perdu quelque chose ce jour-là mais ce n'est pas
comme ça que cette histoire se termine
[Musique]
pour les joueurs que
vous